[Musik]
im rat was wären wir zwei hauptschüler
hier im kalten arbeiten sitzen erträgen
im büro und spielen der mangas spiele
die baumgasse business spielen verarscht
mich jetzt ja cookies an die halten uns
zu blöd glaube du hast dich ja nicht so
hager
jetzt erst recht in china viermal über
120 jetzt gibts doch eine kunstrichtung
das gibt es doch nicht was macht er
hallo
märz was ist los was macht ihr gerade
das habt ihr gerade gemacht was machst
du gerade
was ich das machen was nach china war
später greifen wir sind nach draußen und
für baustellen mit frieden uns den
hintern auf und ihr spielt hier
computerspiele bompas wieso habt ihr
nicht gemacht was ich das was das was
ist das bompas die verarscht mich nicht
mehr hundertprozentig sagt ehrlich geht
es noch mal online
public ich bin definitiv zu alt ich bin
definitiv zu alt für dieses spiel
ok also ich bin nicht so alt für karaoke
und ich bin definitiv nicht so alt für
verkleidungen und karneval
ich bin augen zu alt für mario kart im
reallife und ich bin definitiv nicht zu
alt für anna und so bist du eine schiene
war es noch nie
aber ich bin zu alt für ramos ich
verstehe es später hat vielleicht etwas
mehr sanieren oder eine außentür hi mein
name ist sally und ich gebe mein bestes
um eine am morgen aus torte
hinzubekommen
vielleicht sollte ich mal einen
livestream machen mit und mit ihm spiel
der zockt ist im live stream
deswegen
[Musik]
und je was hat sich denn jetzt drauf
ein schock hat heute recht schoko banane
oder schoko banane sowie maulwurf kuchen
und oben drauf sitzt die 3d figur aus
rheydt crosby superlecker die rote und
dann machen wir noch eine kopfbedeckung
für den rücken nämlich 42 100 g zucker
eine prise salz etwas von den extrakt
jeweils 200 muttermilch und
sonnenblumenöl zwei reife bananen 130
gramm mandeln die werden gleich gemahlen
250 gramm mehl 50 gramm cacau 50 gramm
schokostreusel drei teelöffel backpulver
und etwas zimt ok sieht nach ziemlich
viel aus aber es wird halt ein leckerer
schokolade bananen kuchen
ich werde zuerst mal die mandel fein
mahlen
ich könnte aber auch gerne schon
gemahlene verwenden
ich gebe jetzt hier einfach auch direkt
noch die bananen mit rein
wie gesagt wir dürfen schon sehr sehr
sehr reif sein oder ist er braun das
nicht direkt und damit sich gut parieren
lässt einfach noch wie zwei
flüssigkeiten butter milch und öl
jetzt bereue ich hier die eier mit dem
zucker salz und vanille extrakt so ganz
weiß cremig
[Musik]
jetzt könnt ihr hier die flüssigen
zutaten kurz einrühren
aber wirklich nur vorsichtig um die
trockenen die sieben stationen hebt er
dann kurz unter schokostreusel nicht
vergessen
vorsichtig unterheben den ofen habe ich
ja bereits vorgeheizt und ich mache die
torte jetzt 25 cm groß später nämlich
die garagen bord und macht aber den ring
ein bisschen kleiner als die gagen
boards und zwar deswegen weil ich später
die gamaschen boards benutzer zum
richtigen glatt streichen
also am besten so 24,5 ungefähr dass so
ein minimaler rand hier ist also ist es
auch hier ganz gut so das kann natürlich
wegnehmen dann den teig einfüllen und
kurz backen und in der zwischenzeit
kümmere ich mich schon mal um die
schokoladen bringen
[Musik]
für die schokoladencreme also für die
ghana schnee mich 300 gramm sahne und
600 gramm zartbitterschokolade die sahne
wird jetzt einfach aufgekocht das könnt
ihr auf dem herd im topf machen oder in
der küchenmaschine wenn er eine habt mit
hitze funktion
ich nehme die kenwood da geht es auch
super schnell denn die hat ja ein
induktionskochfeld hier kurz aufkochen
lassen
normalerweise nehme ich mittlerweile
kuratieren chips aber ich habe noch so
viel schokolade in meiner schokolade
schublade ja ich habe eine schokoladen
schublade
deswegen versuche ich immer gerade bei
einer garage alle reste aufzubrauchen
als ihr könnt wirklich jede art von
schokolade nehmen hier ist jetzt nur
wichtig da peter schokolade wegen einem
engen verhältnis falls ihr weiße
schokolade oder vollmilch nimmt schaut
einfach in mein block vorbei ein
grundrezept am arsch
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich die hitze ausschalten
wenn ihr auf dem herd arbeitet die den
top form herunter ziehen und die
schokolade dazu geben und dann kurz
berühren bis die schokolade geschmolzen
ist
ich finde ich als um und lasse dann
schön auf zimmertemperatur abkühlen
mittlerweile ist der kuchen auch
gebacken
den habe ich jetzt hier 15 minuten
abkühlen lassen löse jetzt hier den ring
zidan debug folie darunter weg und lasst
den kuchen komplett erhalten
jetzt kommt mein lieblings part und ich
glaube auch sehr max beliebt linkspartei
nämlich die rays crispy masse die liebt
jeder und zwar werde ich die figur oben
ich kann dir auch ausfuhren zubereiten
gar kein problem dann backt sie einfach
mehr kuchen
aber mein team liebt auch reis
christie's daher wird die figur oben aus
treis christie's gemacht dafür brauche
ich hier diese show cross ich habe
marshmallows ich habe butter schoko
cookies und marshmallows in gleichen
teilen dann ein wenig butter und weil
wir auch lockeres leben das sind diese
das ist die resteverwertung die ich aus
schokolade gerne mache habe ich jetzt
hier gedacht machen wir doch mal race
christmas rock n roll
also machen wir noch gefriergetrocknete
himbeeren erdnüsse salzbrezeln und
cranberries dazu im ersten schritt
schmerzt jetzt einfach die marshmallows
entweder in der pfanne oder viel viel
einfacher in der mikrowelle
so mache ich das und werde in der
zwischenzeit diese zutaten hier ein
bisschen zerkleinern
[Musik]
sie sehen jetzt mich heiß aus aber
glaubt mir diesen richtig heiß also
nicht rein fassen die butter schmilzt
drin und ich weiß sieht am anfang ein
bisschen eklig aus aber die macht es
echt mega lecker da gibt es sogar in
amerika so einen schokoriegel und jetzt
kommen sie hier rein
man hätte auch eine größere schüssel
nehmen können und damit jetzt wirklich
also das wird jetzt echte lücke
ich glaube ich habe ein bisschen zu gut
kann man schnell mal die hälfte
jetzt die hände mit bisschen back trance
brave hätten oder mit öl oder butter
denn gleich werde ich das einfach nur
noch verkneten aber erst wenn es nicht
mehr so heiß ist
die torte wieder so groß und die figur
soll rosetta und jetzt durch
zusammendrücken und klopfen und die
dieser masse schön festigen und in form
bringen
was müsst ihr halt machen solange sie
noch warm ist und formbar ist ja ich
glaube ich auch gleich noch mal die
gleiche masse denn ich war schon eine
große figur also spielt das netz um
geizen so ein bisschen flach oben rund
so die grundformen passt das mache ich
kurz die gleiche masse noch mal
[Musik]
das mail app dann die beine
ich glaube ich drittel das jetzt einfach
genau ein drittel für den rucksack ein
drittel 1 1 ein drittel bei
also diese reis christina city wird
schon relativ schnell fest das heißt
wenn ihr die zubereitet dann wirklich
auch so wie bei mir erst mal die hälfte
machen für den körper und dann noch mal
die andere hälfte für beine und rucksack
vor allem hier auch sondern steinplatte
künste schnell ab was mir jetzt muss ich
sagen gut kommt weil ich arbeite ja auch
recht schnell und kann jetzt hier
praktisch das formen und sozusagen hier
die kälte schön mit nutzen dass ich
schneller vorankommen
aber auch bei mir ich hätte nicht die
komplette menge nehmen können weil
ansonsten wird die masse recht schnell
fest
und dann habe ich im prinzip meine
grundform der rucksack ein bisschen groß
die beiden bis dahin und kürzen und
hinten dicker machen das geht so und die
figur dass die mir jetzt nicht zusammen
sagt werde ich jetzt erst mal hinlegen
und liegend fest werden lassen denn die
schwerkraft sorgt natürlich dafür dass
die nach unten zusammen sagt aber von
den proportionen und her passt das dazu
zu schneiden kann ist dann immer noch
das lasse ich jetzt fest werden und
sobald der kuchen abgekühlt ist kann ich
mich um die füllung gewarnt und das ist
man
ich mache jetzt eine quark sahne füllung
aus 500 gramm quark 80 gramm puderzucker
wandel extrakt 400 gramm sahne eine
sonderfahrt zum schlagen und schokoladen
blättchen zuerst stehen quark mit
puderzucker und wann ein extrakt
verrühren und wenn das verrührt ist die
sahne langsam dazu geben
die frau die auch den saga welche aus
kratzt lassen sich dann danach habe ich
noch irgendwo sagen und dann pro 100
gramm flüssige masse also sein oder
quark einen teelöffel seiner partner zu
geben und die masse schreib schlagen die
perfekte saale gräben und jetzt noch die
schoko blättchen rein kurz unterheben
und dann stelle ich die krähen kurz in
den kühlschrank und kann den tortenboden
schon mal durchschneiden
jetzt kann ich den topfboden
durchschneiden und zwar zweimal das
passwort der tortenboden war halt etwas
anderes dieser torten ist ein bisschen
fester aber saftig aber muss segen
vielleicht schafft es noch also
insgesamt vier böden schneiden dann
nehme ich jetzt den untersten boden der
komplett drauf die creme fülle ich in
einen spritzbeutel ihr könnt auch ohne
spritzbeutel auftragen aber so geht s
gleichmäßiger cool aus da drin
jetzt kann ich hier die torte film und
zwar achte ich jetzt darauf dass die
sahne creme nicht bis an den rand kommt
denn da werde ich von außen mit der gage
einfach verschließen und hier als ein
bisschen rand lassen
dann gibt es da noch einen rand und die
füllung könnt ihr jetzt so aufteilen
dass sie wirklich in allen drei
schichten passt also ein bisschen man
müsste sie dann augenmaß technisch
koordinieren dass es passt ich gebe
jetzt noch bananen rein das ist wirklich
wieso maulwurfs kuchen einem anruf torte
maulwurf dort mal so hoch war wie ein
kuchen die torte
ich meine natürlich ist eine torte bei
der maulwurf heute weiß ich dass man sie
so längst
[Musik]
ich mach scheibe dass es nicht so dicke
mit bisschen creme bedecken
es ist nämlich hier den deckel und damit
die torte weiterhin gewahrt wird drehen
einfach um den deckel und so fühle ich
jetzt die komplette flotte die torte die
wird so lecker ich sag's euch die wird
es da wirklich spaß aber mit der
krümmung der vierte boden der war
einfach zu viel
ihr könnt übrigens die garage also
eigentlich mache ich es immer so dass
ich einen ring aus garath außen auf
spritze damit die torte erst gar nicht
so nach außen herunter fällt aber meine
garage noch nicht kalt genug deswegen
mache ich diesmal so erste füllung und
später kommt die garage an der anrainer
wäre es natürlich andere strom
und wenn die bananen dann so abgedeckt
sind kommt der letzte boden drauf jaha
siehe da
und dann kann die torte erstmal gekühlt
werden ich kann hier aufräumen gucken
dass die gespült und dann die torte
rundherum bestreichen
die torten kühl sein überbrücke ich
jetzt mit dem menschen hier habe ich ja
wie gesagt schon den körper dann den
rucksack und eigentlich wollte ich den
rucksack jetzt noch richtig knackig zu
schneiden aber ich glaube es passt so
zum comic stil dass es so leicht
abgerundet ist an den ecken oben also
von daher passt ich muss mal gucken es
einmal rechtwinklig schneiden nur dann
steht es hier nämlich perfekt das passt
und die beine die muss ich noch ein
bisschen anpassen
reyes crispy salami
dann bin ich mit den metzger tätigkeiten
erst mal fertig und damit die figur
später auch schön glatt wird und mit von
hand gezogen werden kann werde ich sehe
jetzt mit der garage einstreichen
position mehreren schichten machen als
ich streiche jetzt schon mal eine
schicht draufstellen die figur dann kühl
dann kommt die nächste drauf und so wird
es ja einfach nach und nach geknetet
jetzt habe ich hier meine garage auch in
einem spritzbeutel geht auch ohne ihr
könnt es auch wie gesagt vor dem
befüllen der torte mache und auf jeden
tortenboden praktischen ring aus ghana
spritzen damit die sahne creme einfach
nicht an und fondant kommt das lasse ich
jetzt kurz im gefrierfach oder im
kühlschrank fest werden und dann kann
ich die torte schön glatt streichen
guckt mal wenn die garage kalt ist dann
tragen sie einfach noch eine zweite
dünne schicht auf und könnte dann mit so
einer flexiblen teig karte die teile
einfach schön glatt streichen
die rundung oder vorne sich mit dieser
toten rand folie einfach glatt
ihr könnt auch einen abschnitt von einem
joghurtbecher zum beispiel neben pozzato
flexibel
[Musik]
jetzt werde ich hier diese unperfekte
torte gleich perfekt glatt streichen und
deswegen nehme ich jetzt diese garagen
boards und platziert die torte drauf ein
garagen board unter der torte eins oben
drauf und alles was ihr hier jetzt an
lücken sät wird praktisch mit der creme
ausgefüllt und so bekomme ich hin dass
die torte gleich perfekt ist
[Musik]
ich sage heute läuft so geschmeidig
heute war die torte sicherung aber ihr
seht auch aus einer krummen torten nicht
gleichmäßigen bananen stücken wird
gleich eine gerade torte sobald der rams
dann schön glatt ist könnt ihr das obere
gagen dort nämlich abnehmen und noch die
oberfläche schönen glätten
ich müsste halt gerade noch eine portion
gemacht deswegen funktioniert das
funktioniert heute nicht so glatt
streichen aber kommen das sieht man am
ende hoffentlich nicht aber damit ihr
auch mal sehen ich wollte nicht zu viel
machen dann war es zu wenig dann wieder
zu wenig dann dachte ich jetzt auf rom
zu geizen
jetzt habe ich im endeffekt dreimal
ganache macht oder träume ja vielleicht
für euch als tipp falls jemals so viel
übrig habt könnt ihr sie ein freund für
heute habe ich genug gearbeitet die tor
des gefüllt sie ist glatt gestrichen
dass er morgen tierchen männchen ist
auch im kühlschrank und morgen geht's
weiter mit der torten denken
heute ist nicht alle tage ich komm
wieder keine frage ein neuer tag und
heute ist ein guter tag für fondant ich
werde hier unten des cushing wort
erstmal ablösen das heißt einmal kurz
die torte umdrehen
das möchte ich jetzt nicht drunter
behalten ihr könnt jetzt im prinzip auch
drunter behalten aber das kann ein
schwimmbad ist doch ziemlich glatt und
rutschig und ich will nicht dass mir
später die top evo runter rutscht
außerdem will ich nicht drauf schneiden
obwohl es sehr kraft rest ist ich nehme
hier im jackpot grund hat das hat jetzt
den vorteil dass wenn ich die torte
gleich umdrehen und ich mit fondant
arbeite muss sich die torte auch mal weg
bewegen können wenn es jetzt komplett
ohne habt habt ihr im prinzip den
tortenboden einfach unten
und wenn euch dann mal war es weg
bringen dann ist halt nicht ganz so gut
deswegen nehme ich einfach in der größe
da kann ich auch drauf schneiden das ist
zwar aus pappe und beschichtet aber man
kann es auch mehrfach besetzen können da
einfach abwaschen kurz bisschen gaga ich
habe immer so ein bisschen garage noch
übrig die benutze ich dann hier so zum
kleben
und dann habe ich hier das fertige
törtchen kleine ausbesserungen
vielleicht da unten und dann kann ich
schon mal ein kilo fondant da nehme ich
jetzt natürlich schwarz schön weich
kneten und zum beispiel hätten benutze
ich damals einfach so ein bisschen
kokosöl für die hände
da habe ich jetzt ein kilo
ihr braucht jetzt auch keine angst haben
also es kommt jetzt nicht ein kilo
fondant auf die torte aber man braucht
natürlich zum ausrollen ein bisschen
mehr und der restwert an weggeschnitten
so kann dann gelagert werden und kommt
dann einfach bei der nächsten trotz zum
einsatz also fondant wird daher in der
hinsicht nicht schlecht ich kenne das
jetzt hier schön weich
[Musik]
und wenn davon land dann schön weich ist
dann schön ausrollen
ich mache das immer gerne auf becker
stärke becker stellte es nämlich keine
speisestärke sondern eine reine
kartoffelstärke und die club nicht und
die kann ich später ganz einfach mit
einem pinsel wieder wegwischen davon
dann klebt dann auch nicht und jetzt
kann ich ihnen schön dünn ausrollen
ich habe hier auch sein fondant den
benutzer schon seit jahren von dem kino
und der ist mit shea butter kennt
palmfett und das ist echt super super
weich und vor allem reis der nicht und
ist sehr elastisch also das ist echt gut
dann kann man das schön dünn auf die
torte auftragen und hat mich schon eine
dicke von dampf schicht wenn ihr so luft
blitzten habt die kinder einfach
aufstecken und ströber wollen dann sieht
man den nicht mehr
dann können wir die decke hier kurz
aufrollen
die torte ins bild holen
und falls jetzt die oberfläche also
diese ghana schon ausgetrocknet ist also
schön kalt ist soll sie auch dann könnt
ihr hier mit bisschen back transport
übergehen damit er vom landgut haftet
dann gibt es da keine luftbläschen
dann kommt die von dann decke jetzt
drüber und ihr streicht jetzt im prinzip
von oben nach unten also erstmal die
oberfläche klippen und die luft unten
drunter wegstreichen und damit sieht die
eine hand immer die vom land decke und
die andere glättet den rand und so
arbeitet wie jetzt von oben nach unten
wenn es dann aussieht wie ein hut habt
ihr echt alles richtig gemacht dann
schneidet ihr hier unten
den rest weg ich nehme dafür immer so ja
ich nenne es eigentlich nicht mehr
marzipan messer weil ich da jetzt
wirklich alles schneiden kann sein
modell messer das nämlich flexibel
schneidet debatte nicht durch und
dadurch dass es eine stumpfe schärfe ist
heißt es denn fondant nicht
dann nämlich die bäcker stärke immer so
ein bisschen runter kann es wieder
zusammen kneten und einfach luftdicht
verpacken und für die nächste tochter
aufbewahren
man könnte hier die bäcker stärke
wegnehmen und dann nimm dir zwei vom
band kletter und belebt die torte wieder
nein ich hätte die oberfläche und den
rand und es geht halt so eigentlich
extrem einfach vor allem wenn ihr vorher
die tore schön platt gemacht habt dann
ist das im endeffekt nur ein kinderspiel
so werden die kanten so abgerundet volt
können dass sie so lassen oder ihr nehmt
sondern kanten forma dann können dass
sie so ein bisschen eckiger gestalten
ich zeige euch aber gleich noch eine
andere technik ohne ecken form und ohne
ecken glitter nehmt ihr einfach die
torte dreht sie um
da war nämlich dann die upside down
technik
nur einen kurzen moment riskant
dann könnten nämlich hier ganz einfach
mit so einem normalen blätter die ecke
hier nach unten drücken und sozusagen
die ecke so nach unten formen
gehört die torte jetzt erst mal
überzogen kommen den kühlschrank und
dann kümmere ich mich um die männchen
und dafür werde ich jetzt roten von dann
treten oder nicht
ich weiß nicht überlegt kurz ich
überlegte mir also ich habe mich
entschieden ich nehme der commerzbank
weil der einfach lecker schmeckt ich
habe jetzt hier diese verschiedenen
teile und ich würde zuerst einmal die
grosse figur mit der decke einschlagen
und da geht es im prinzip genauso wie
mit fondant einfach dünn ausrollen auf
becker stärke und es ist schon so ein
angelegter marzipan also dass dies
praktisch zum ausrollen zum dekorieren
zu modellieren muss man nichts mehr
machen
eingefärbt ware auch schon
und die figur könnte jetzt entweder
stehend überziehen oder ihr macht so ich
mache mir auch ein bisschen einfach
nicht überzieht sie so und schneidet den
rest hinten am rücken weg denn im rücken
da kommt er sowieso der rucksack ihren
da sieht man es dann nicht wie jetzt
gerade mit back transfer eingeführt aber
ich denke trotzdem gut da hinten einfach
mal mit einer schere grob wegschneiden
besten muss erstmal eine falte das hier
mache ist dann so damit ein glatter
übergang wird einmal hier einschneiden
und jetzt kann ich das hier wegnehmen
und hier das darunter wegnehmen und
sauber verbinden dann habt ihr nicht so
eine beule das packe ich jetzt hier nach
unten damit einfach so nach unten nicht
abgeschnitten aussieht sondern rund
aussieht
[Musik]
setze meine torte direkt auf die
tortenplatte auf der ich sie servieren
will ok die platte rutscht ich lege
jetzt das tot
[Musik]
wie ist dort jetzt noch ein bisschen zu
matsch ich werde jetzt so ein bisschen
mit fett hier so ein bisschen mit
bakterien spray bruder bzw bepinseln
so gefällt mir richtig gut weil eben
warten wir ein bisschen zum mars muss
ich sagen und so durch ein bisschen
wachstum spray hab ich so schön nicht zu
glänzen aber perfekt du kriegst gleich
eine kinder schützen
orange die ausgesperrt kevin hat sich
ausgesperrt da kommt nicht rein
ich mach jetzt hier so eine galaxie
torte heraus kannst du vielleicht aus
marzipan die morgens figuren modellieren
also sowie vom land ganz okay okay da
mach ich dir jetzt hier platz und das
hier mal weg aber du kannst du schon so
klein machen so süß und ich nehme das
plötzlich musste ich kann nebenher
meiner galaxie torte machen
ich hab jetzt mit weißer
lebensmittelfarbe passte einfach kleine
punkte auf die torte das geht am besten
entweder mit einem pinsel oder mit so
einem ball tool zum bord holt er ist
halt direkt schon perfekte rund
[Musik]
das sieht das aus wie ein universum
sieht das aus wie die galaxie ja kommen
hier kam es hingegen zum trocknen dass
der rucksack
obwohl du kannst auch so
naja guck dir sitzen ja auch so
dann stehst du die beine kannst du
sitzen lassen
ich mag den einen das handy das ein
handy hat den rucksack kannst du hinten
dran
[Musik]
und jetzt muss ich mir überlegen wo die
figur drauf sitzen soll ich denke ich
platz sehr recht weit hier
denn die beine damit sie nicht
runterfällt und nicht in die torte ein
sagt durch ihr gewicht werde ich die
torte jetzt mit dübeln also mit cake
pops tags versehen so vielleicht wartest
du kurz und dann am besten wenn im
lebensmittel stift hier kurz an zeichnen
und dann kann ich nämlich kürzen und
wenn ich dann die figur drauf setzte
dann drückt es die torte nicht ein
wo eigentlich wollte ich ganz viele
kleine machen aber der sehr mag hat sich
eine große figur gewünscht ich glaube
weil der sehr mag race crispy mag kann
das sein
dann hab ich die torte schon mal
gedübelt den rucksack möchte ich jetzt
nicht ganz unten anlegen sondern
wirklich so bisschen erhöht daher nehme
ich jetzt hier zahnstocher
beziehungsweise schaschlikspieß die
kommen diese noch ein bisschen zu lang
die kommen jetzt hier rein immer noch so
cool
jetzt kommt die da drauf direkt auf die
gedeckelte stelle passt ja warum nicht
und dann kommt noch die beine dran aber
bevor ich die jetzt mache werde ich hier
noch oben dieses schild oder mache ich
erst meine erste beine und zu habe ich
jetzt hier so einen kleinen rand
gelassen den schneide ich jetzt ganz
kurz sauber jetzt kann ich nämlich mit
dem marzipan was am randes das ist
einfach so ein bisschen andrücken und in
form bringen und dann entsteht da
einfach keine lücke
und da ist die torte jetzt nicht weg
transportieren werde sondern weil wir
sie zu hause essen werde ich da jetzt
auch nichts mehr daran befestigen
sondern ich lege es einfach wirklich nur
so locker dran
falls ihr die torte aber
wegtransportiert dann würde ich schon
die beine auch daran heften dass die
nicht abhalten
dann könnten nämlich einfach auch so
einen schaschlikspieß nehmen oder einen
zahnstocher und im prinzip ein mal hier
rein
da zeigt sich jetzt an dem einen und
stammen eben da dran
das schild nicht eckig habt ihr dürft
auch so leicht abrunden
dann kommt mit kleber direkt auf die
torte das ist ein essbarer kleber da
wirklich einfach nur ganz sparsam
umgehen
kurz verstreichen
[Musik]
die ecken die runde ich jetzt noch
besser ab denn das ganze stadt doch
ziemlich eine runde sache sind nicht so
scharfkantig perfekt
um das schild hier jetzt so ein bisschen
metallic farben zu bekommen nämlich
einfach mit alex sprayen silber und das
kann man entweder sprühen oder zum malen
benutzen oder zum basteln
ich spreche jetzt hier in den deckel
rhein kann dann so einem flachen pinsel
nehmen schließt auch ein bisschen
schwarze farbe passte und misch hier
ich kenne den deckel gleich auswaschen
mich hier mit dem metallic dann kann ich
nämlich so ein farbverlauf noch
reinmachen dann sieht es auch ein
bisschen städten comicstil schon sondern
im comic stil ist mit dunkler
jetzt fehlt nur noch eine umrandung hier
einmal drumherum mache ich jetzt noch
kurz aus schwarz und haben wir nicht so
weit fertig fällt dann auch der
schriftzug natürlich die banane die
kopfbedeckung fehlt ja auch noch ich
habe sie kurz gegriffen
doch mal banane hat auch weil es ist
eine bananen torte eigentlicher gestern
fürchten aber nähe wir müssen noch los
zum glück passte auf die kopfbedeckung
vergessen
[Musik]
diese details sind halt schon so das was
uns immer ausmacht okay die torte kommen
jetzt mal ganz kurz in kühlschrank wenn
sie von der höhe her reinpasst wenn ich
komm tzu vor die tür
ich freue mich hier kurz auf und dann
machen wir noch den kopfschmuck der
fällt noch und natürlich vorne dann noch
das logo habe ich erwähnt dass dieses
video nicht produkt platziert ist also
die spielen das hat oben und deswegen
machen wir jetzt kommt noch der hwz
sozusagen den kann man sich ja aussuchen
und ich dachte weil der wechsel bananen
torte ist mache ich eine bananenschale
eine echte band schale mit halt braun
irgendwann mit der zeiten außerdem will
ich sie auch aus kuchen machen
ich habe extra in porec die banane rein
um euch zu zeigen sich die banane machen
möchte nämlich so aber vier geteilt denn
auf den bildern bei amras ist es auch
noch vier geteilt und so ein bisschen
mehr komik das heißt ich nehme es
bisschen gelben fondant und damit dieser
auch schon aushärten kann wird der
einfach mit zellulose gemischt also mit
csc prüfer das wird hier ein geknetet
und führt den inneren part nämlich
marzipan
der hat nämlich schon die perfekte farbe
so wie ich es brauche nicht ganz weiß
sondern er so wenn ich also ich habe
noch nie eine banane gemacht so anfang
[Musik]
und dann hat ja die banane innen so ein
bisschen struktur da nehme ich jetzt
einen schaschlikspieß macht das jetzt
auch so
dann damit dass oben gehören noch bis
einschneiden
[Musik]
und das gebe ich jetzt sehe weil sich
hier ein
[Musik]
von unten sieht man sehr 100 deswegen
habe ich trete für ein bisschen deswegen
also die unterseite
wenn ihr die schale nur von außen sieht
dann sieht man es nicht so aber ich will
es so ein bisschen drehen dass man es
sieht
daher mache ich jetzt hier diese
struktur auch noch ein wunsch damit das
ganze noch ein bisschen realer wird hier
noch mit pulver farbe in braun und
schwarz einfach so ein paar
schattierungen und flecken drauf machen
das mache ich jetzt in dem pinsel und an
manchen stellen werde ich es aber auch
mit back trends bei machen das ist so
ein bisschen ja eigentlich wie flüssige
farbe wird und dann kann ich hier
einfach so diese schale sondern schauen
das bisschen bis in nachahmung also für
fein hätten nämlich dann dünnen pinsel
und für die schattierungen nämlich immer
so ein flug wegen pinsel habe jetzt echt
glücklich seid ja hab ich denn damit
kann ich einfach hier schöne
schattierungen machen und das ganze
schön verblenden wie beim make-up die
feinen linien vom 1 1 hat sich mit einem
dünnen pinsel und die schattierungen
macht mitten im flug
ich nehme den als neuen gruppen bilden
aber an anderen nicht gehen
[Musik]
ok seid ihr bereit für die banane
also ich hatte ja auch und familien kopf
aber ich für die banane schoss er
schlägt da einfach so eine bananenstaude
auf das habe aber ich müsste ich glaube
ich mache sie so dass der obere noch so
bisher
ich mache da was drunter kurz sowieso
ein kegel weil auf den bildern ist sie
auch immer noch so zylinderförmige das
ist schon gut dass man das nicht sehen
denn ich brauche erstmal st
das ist so lustig jetzt setze ich mich
kurz an die technik und werden nach den
weißen schriftzug machen damit nicht
fertig
[Musik]
also ich hole jetzt mal sehr mag und
aline die zwei sind ein haushalt warum
sollen sich selber ich sage das nur weil
letztes mal jemand sagt hey warum essen
die von einem teller
zwei dinge haben zusammen das leben das
ich war auch gut sagen das ist ob es nur
die ist aus marzahn und fondant lexus
die sulzer ist also was tatsächlich
sagen dass ich wollte ja ursprünglich so
alle figuren klein machen und die idee
von dir 3d oben draufsetzen er war
chocolat
also man erkennt direkt ob mit dem gut
dass man sich auswählen kann
wahrscheinlich dachte ich mache ich habe
ich das dahin gemacht aber dann aber es
war aber dann kam ich auf die banane
weil ich eine schoko bananen potter
gemacht habe die übernahme sieht das
einfach weiß christa bringen globisch
ist wie hast du dir gewünscht
ja dann wird hierzu ein posten der in
prostata vertreter du willst unseren to
make a
ich wollte schon immer weil der mörder
sein
wenn dann mord aus liebe navi blind
getroffen haben sie jetzt als in postdam
ist eigentlich leugnen dass du es bist
ich war sonst ja auch ich wer hat den
keks aus der dose
nein du oh ja doch sehr mag hat den keks
aus der dose geklaut ich ja du nie was
also das mag schon sein aber das
anzuschneiden ich stand noch mal das
andere
[Musik]
sie schneiden wir jetzt
ich glaube wir müssen tatsächlich einmal
da vornherein okay das bisschen
buttercreme sind unter naja ich habe wie
ein maulwurf kochen heißt hier
buttercreme und von dort geht alles den
kombi feiert
ich stelle es mir hier zu fahren
ich habe ich habe eine ein maulwurf
kuchen gebacken was mit bananen und
schokolade und streicheln
ich schmeiße basso und später steigen
ständig von deutschland sieht immer so
cool aus
zu eineinhalb tage gebaut und dann
zerstört
so dürft ihr probieren manchmal macht
man es dann über kreuz
ja aber der schritt hat man sich auch
ganz banale sauguten ist auch viele
bananen zurück das führte
wir frieren was einzelne beziehungsweise
schicken sie ihm einfach nach hause
das ist der ist ja okay also das war ja
das video zur torte blieb sie einfach an
euch und ihr könnt damit machen wir
bringen
heute war ich sehr mörder und verräter
ich hab überhaupt kommen
natürlich haben uns schämen gewinnen
leute zu ackerbau gibt toscani
herausschneiden das ist ein anfang
[Musik]